hey guys merry here at PAX Prime 2015
and we're working with the mix to bring
you guys the latest and greatest indie
games and I am here with Jeff and Paul
and you guys are from Ken dessin games
yeah this is you get it yeah and you
guys are gonna show us tuner [ __ ] today
yeah the rocket jumping platform all
right let's jump right in alright so the
main hook of Tanisha is that it's a
platform without a jump on so instead of
hitting next to Ron and ate a jump like
we've been doing for 30 years we use the
right stick to shoot rockets in any
direction okay shooter that your feet
explosion pops you up and now you're
doing quake 3 tf2 style rocket jumping
awesome see short quick tough levels now
unlike in tf2 though it's not gonna
damage you when you rocket jump yourself
oh no not at all your robot you can
handle it so tell me a little bit about
like the goals of this game you're
trying to go for speed or precision when
you're when you're beating these levels
a little bit of both it starts off um
you're just trying to survive through
the levels but the mechanic is a lot
like rocket jumping you can gain a lot
of speed in a lot of momentum as long as
you can keep connecting your Rockets
long services you're just gonna keep
getting faster and faster okay so your
food actually propels you as long as
you're connecting your rocket exactly
there's no cap on the speed or anything
like that so there's no cap nope okay so
in theory you can consistently go so
fast in this game yeah if you continue
to do it alright well that's awesome so
it's showing you like um maybe as you
progress you get a little bit more
skilled you're gonna start to see some
really intense jumps um it looked like
you could almost jump over that area can
you manipulate the levels to get things
through things faster later on as you
learn them better oh absolutely yeah the
level design is all very abusable it's
kind of interesting because everybody
picks up a game finds a new way to go
through the level they use two rockets
here one over there they connect our
momentum so every time someone picks up
the game and just get surprised at how
they tackle one of these
and it um it looks like even for someone
who's played the game a lot this is non
easy game it could actually it's going
to take some skill to get around yeah
it's in the vein of a lot of these games
where we're we're trying to make it
tough challenging but not overly
frustrates you want to punch your TV and
where are we in it this is like in the
very beginning and the shortest age yeah
so it gets way harder from here yeah
absolutely how many levels you guys have
so far we are coming out on thursday and
we have 66 levels total seven worlds and
every group of nine ten worlds is capped
with ten levels is capped with a boss
fight okay that's cool you can see these
replays so if you do a particularly
awesome thing which you can kind of go
back you can speed it up and slow it
down and we have some custom camera
angles they're seeking kind of takes in
some glamour shots baby welding here
yeah he looks really good and if there's
a particular part you're stuck on you
can go to the leaderboards and watch
their every place as well can you change
the angles in the leaderboard videos as
well oh yeah alright so it was you can
actually make some pretty dynamic videos
wait with what you've made here montage
oh yeah and you probably will find that
to write like somebody who's had such
amazing luck with their rocket jumps you
can put them in slow motion get them at
all these different angles and basically
make a sweet compilation of it yeah so
it looks like this is a boss fight yeah
this is our first boss named a cyclops
okay well you'd think that would be a
good thing but that guy doesn't look
nice well your metal so you he wants the
recycling this is the first time in a
while I've seen recycling be evil yeah
that's a good point all right so you're
just basically running as fast as you
can kind of like a little bit of a super
meat boy vibe to it yeah definitely
inspired by that kind of short
challenging tight level design where
you're gonna die a bunch but you're only
gonna lose 57 seconds of progress
gracious are you joining the process as
well like it's like earlier when you
were dying like you're just kind of
jumping right back into the fray so
you're not losing too much time stop
telling you the problem it's not there's
no dying screen was like wow well
yeah go back do it again and keep
playing and you guys are kind of keeping
the momentum going got lots of like
vivid colors and fast paced music you
want people to like get into the zone
and just keep going here absolutely you
got again that Zen state how do you know
when those lasers are going to kill you
when they turn red when you're touching
them they're turning red so you can only
touch them for so long trip it and then
it fires I stand there a little sriracha
yeah we try to introduce a new mechanic
for every world so this world there's a
lot of lasers yeah since you keep your
you keep the you don't get any new
skills you don't get any new XP it's
just you got your skill set and then we
throw crazy geometry and interesting
level design yeah oh and being of like
the geometry like it's really
interesting that obviously you want to
focus on what you're about to be doing
and all the platforming that's happening
but the backgrounds are really
interesting is well like they're they're
really beautifully designed there's all
sorts of stuff back there to like enjoy
and look at yeah that's why you got to
slow it down on the replay enjoy
yourself in the replay like only get
camera angles that show off how good the
background looks yeah all right let's
see a little boy here and and you guys
said this is that it looks pretty
finalized like this is yeah remaking my
own Thursday yeah we've been in early
access for a year now and we've finished
all our content or just you know
wrapping everything up and launch it on
steam pc linux max thursday September
third well that's awesome Paul and Jeff
thank you so much for showing us to
nourish us so this is coming out really
soon you guys can pick it up how much is
this game right now uh it was fifteen
fifteen dollars on there awesome and
that is tuner [ __ ] thank you guys so
much for showing me like a no thank you
and for everything else you guys need
you'd be sure to stay tuned to gamespot
com
you